stop the wedding and smile for the
camera because it's episode 5 of the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina and this
one is sure to put you to sleep see see
see what I did there okay I'll stop
while Sabrina is in her room dealing
with the Acheron hilda and Zelda enjoy a
nice book Hilda's reading the turncoat
by Donna thorolund romance novel set in
1777 and seems to be enjoying it
thoroughly it makes so much sense as to
why Hilda would fall in love with this
book in particular but I'll get into
that a bit later
Zelda on the other hand is reading the
good old Dark Lord Satanic Bible as
Hilda mentioned she wants to work at
doctor services Sabrina comes screaming
through the door to let everyone know
she's free to demon into the house but
no worries as the saying goes anything
that comes out of an Akron can be put
back into an Akron except Sabrina left
her with the demon Zelda Hilda and
Sabrina escaped through this neat secret
passageway that seems to run all
throughout the house meanwhile Ambrose
has gotten his latest issue of masculine
shape which I can only assume he reads
for the articles before he hears the
commotion upstairs fortunately for
everyone Zelda has protocols in place
for our rampant demon they seal the
house with a spell to prevent it
escaping into the outside world before
begin a chant in Latin which roughly
translate to spirit of the air and your
almighty power buying this entrance at
trap for this demon my Latin translation
is imperfect Translate but I've noticed
a number of the incantations in this
show have called to this spirit of the
air the demon appears from upstairs and
seems to have a real grudge against the
Spellman's looks like Papa Spellman had
her trapped in the Acheron for 70 years
and she is pissed and what's the first
thing you do when you're pissed off and
ready for revenge you turn on some tunes
naturally her song of choice is dream a
little dream by Ella Fitzgerald because
after all this is a sleep demon think
Freddy Krueger at this point it seems as
if nothing happens but the song actually
puts everyone to sleep so when aunt
Zelda pulls out an urn and traps the
demon it's all actually a dream same
goes for the post banishment tea time we
learned that Sabrina's dad suffered from
terrible insomnia because of this sleep
demon and thus trapped it in a puzzle
that only a half-witch could solve
Hilda also mentions she
is foxglove to help her sleep something
that will make an appearance later on in
the episode before bed Sabrina asked
Hilda what would have happened if they
hadn't trapped the demon and lo and
behold she's about to find out
the sleep demon has separated the
Spellman so their dreams can't cross
with each other and then plans to
torment them until one breaks and
releases it from the house
naturally it'll brutally murder them all
as the demon tucks Sabrina in Ward well
pierce through her wet willy mirror and
recognizes the demon she calls it bad
about a demon found in Filipino folklore
I'm a demon a bad about takes the form
of a huge old fat woman sounds about
right here and if you sleep near one
she'll sit on your chest and suffocate
you it is said that to ward off a bad
about you should wiggle your toes or
bite your finger later in the episode
war well uses a prick on Sabrina's
finger to wake her up
badda bat recognizes ward well as the
mother of demons in my episode 3
breakdown I mentioned Ward well seems to
rank higher than Faustus and was
possibly a demon guess she's also the
mother of them Ward well warns the demon
not to harm Sabrina
mommy forbids it but badda-badda spits
and smashes the mirror shattering Ward
wells connection to the room and there's
nothing she can do now the Spellman
house is bound no one in no one out
Sabrina's dream starts at Baxter High
where both her witchly immortal worlds
mold together
she's bullied by The Weird Sisters and
cheerleader uniforms before Nick comes
in and basically complements Sabrina on
her all-around awesomeness but before he
can ask her to prom
enter kinkle and dream Harvey's got more
than just a prom invitation in mind he's
proposing notice the red light here it
makes an appearance in all of Sabrina's
dreams this episode here in the lights
and then again at the ceremony in the
background and then everywhere else you
may have noticed Ambrose hilda and Zelda
have their own colors - Ambrose being
blue check it out in the background here
and the light in his autopsy room
Hilda's is yellow while Zelda's is
purple
you'll also notice places where the
purple and yellow are placed together
which is likely due to how connected the
sisters are back in Sabrina's dream she
tells Harvey while wearing her mother's
wedding dress by the way that she's a
witch but Harvey doesn't seem to care
and everything is sunshine and rainbows
yay Nik makes one last attempt to woo
Sabrina we can hop on this broom and fly
off and have
look back but that ain't happening he
loves me oh and look daddy Spellman is
there to give her away and her family is
there to her friends and principal are
there and oh good weird bunny mask made
it to but unfortunately so did the King
khals who've turned all angry mob on the
place
Harvey betray Sabrina and she gets
thrown into a spiked cage this is
Sabrina's greatest fear being betrayed
by the mortals she loves which is all in
bad ibattz plan all sabrina has to do to
be freed from this torment is tell her
how to break the binding spell next up
is Ambrose he's got to tend to a new
dead body
a tragic shut-in with no friends and no
one to mourn him here we come to one of
Ambrose's greatest fears which is why
it's no surprise that when he and Hilda
open the body bag it's himself stabbed
just like Connor was another one of
Ambrose's fears as Ambrose begins the
autopsy on himself he begins to speak
lines from Shakespeare alas poor Ambrose
I knew him well a famous line from
Hamlet with Ambrose being your this is
from the iconic graveyard scene the one
where Hamlet famously holds the skull of
a jester he knew as a child and just
like what Ambrose is confronting in the
scene its meaning revolves around the
fleeting nature of life Ambrose's use of
Shakespeare here as well as ashes to
ashes dust to dust used in the English
burial service and Genesis 3:19 likely
attributes to his personality is a great
warlock scholar and academic he also
goes all Khaleesi and eats his own heart
apparently it tastes bitter Ambrose then
runs into Ward well who's entered the
dream world in search of Sabrina before
being told he's free from his house
arrest but just as he goes to leave bad
about stabs him like a bajillion times
typical when he awakes he's stuck in his
own body same as earlier in the dream
forced to feel himself being autopsy Don
over and over again third on the docket
is Hilda who gets a call to visit
principal Hawthorne and boy is the
sexual tension high things nearly
explode when Hawthorne says he wants to
cook for her
Hilda prepares for a hot date and dream
Zelda a salami oh this is Hilda's fear
no self-worth who could ever care about
her dream Hawthorne will he set her up
with quite a spread and calls her
voluptuous drunk Hilda sends the stairs
and mentioned she hasn't been this drunk
since Queen Victoria's coronation
which took place in 1838 she was likely
born in that era and considering her
desire to be loved a romance novel set
in 1777 fits the bill perfectly but this
is a nightmare and not a romance
Hawthorne's also got a strange
connection with his sibling he absorbed
him in the womb now I have the strength
of a grown man and a little baby not
only that his brothers guató from Total
Recall while Hilda was passed out he
surgically tied her to Zelda what a
nightmare
last Abbas Elda who's having dark story
time with some children when the weird
sisters dropped by to let her know
Satan's coming over for dinner
Hilda plans to cook him a nice vegetable
pie while Zelda has different plans
Fergus it's what's for dinner
the Dark Lord arrives in naturally Satan
is played by Faustus Blackwood makes
sense considering how the high priest is
the Dark Lord's representative on earth
and also how highly Zelda views him he
asked what's planned for dinner and
chooses to eat Hilda's veggie pie when
he hears the child Zelda cooked was a
child of night and this is one of
Zelda's greatest fears being a
disappointment to the Dark Lord
Zelda goes into hysterics after the Dark
Lord's rejection funny how it's also a
rejection by Blackwood I assume this is
something that happened in reality as
well once the Dark Lord's gone back to
Hell a jealous seldom murders her sister
just as she's done many times before but
this time Hilda isn't getting up and
Zelda's worst fear of all comes true
being without her sister forever back at
the red wedding Miss Wardwell finally
finds Sabrina and lets her know this is
all actually a dream she's gonna wake
sabrina up so she can run the hell away
back in the real world Wardwell gets her
sabrina doll out accessories sold
separately and gives her a prick on her
finger to wake sabrina from the
nightmare bad about goes on a hunt for
Sabrina while she remembers about using
the Acheron to trap the demon once again
no way she's gonna run and leave her
family for dead she visits Ambrose to
try and wake him but he ain't budgin so
Sabrina checks his books for a banishing
spell her best shot right now is to try
and surprise bat a bat and send it
packing into the puzzle downstairs bad
about is looking for Sabrina in a
gramophone when Sabrina gets the jump on
her but Sabrina isn't powerful enough to
get the spell working according to bad
bat she has no power conviction or will
bad about slaps the Acheron out of
Sabrina's hand
smashing it to pieces on the floor and
gashes Sabrina's arms up something
fierce with fingernails that haven't
been clipped in a few centuries before
Sabrina escapes in one of the houses
secret passageways Sabrina makes one
more attempt to wake her family out but
again it has no effect the only way
she'll be able to get help from them is
to go back into the dream world remember
aunt Hilda's mention of foxglove earlier
in the episode Sabrina's gonna use it to
put herself to sleep and reach her
family
Salem Glamour's himself to look like
Sabrina and distracts Freda Krueger
while Sabrina sets a timer for 2 minutes
and goes off into the dream world
undisturbed first she meets with Zelda
the natural first choice for everything
spells but she's far too distraught in
her nightmare to be any help
next is Hilda who actually is very
helpful she says you have to trap the
demon the same way you trap a dream like
with a dreamcatcher and what could be a
better Weaver for a dreamcatcher than
Hilda's familiar the spiders last up is
Ambrose he's going to distract badda bat
as the demon catches up with glamour
Salem she gets a call from Ambrose who's
ready to spill his guts now that his
guts have been spilled enough but it was
all a distraction to give Sabrina time
time to get her in the spiders in place
to dream catch the nightmare and save
the day and everyone awakes trapping
badda-badda way in a super secure jam
jar hope no one gets adventurous with
their cooking spices and forgets after
the ordeal Sabrina gives Harvey a call
for some much-needed comfort and gets
reminded about miss Wardwell visiting
her in the nightmare looks like
someone's got some splainin to do thanks
guys for watching I love putting these
videos together for you I'm gonna try to
get this whole season out as soon as I
can but in the meantime make sure to
like subscribe share you know all that
fun stuff and until next time keep
traveling down that path of night